[Music]  look at the Biebs has a fresh new do and  a new attitude Justin Bieber and Haley  Baldwin were spotted at the Cutler salon  in New York City where Haley is a  regular looking happy and in love as the  24 year old pop star had his long blonde  locks trimmed the newly engaged couple  was all smiles during the outing a far  cry from how they were photographed  earlier this week the sorry singer was  snapped looking visibly emotional with  his head in his hands as Baldwin  seemingly comforted him Justin for the  fans who saw pictures of you crying  can you just reassure him everything's  okay right you got good days you got bad  days  despite the upset the two appear to be  stronger than ever  and are rarely seen apart a source  previously told ET quote justin is in a  really good place and has been telling  friends he's never felt more sure about  a woman in his life  justin is head over heels in love with  Haley I love  you